and monty's ready to go
already throwing his warm-up pitches you
see his numbers
his third start one good one one not so
good one but
back at home towing the slab and the
boogie down looking to get it right back
on track and the yankees really need him
2-2
ground it
right to le meu who was on the left side
of the ship
swing and a tip into the glove
jojo already got grayer but the phil's
held on
that one's popped up
and torres puts it away
tousant see that last start for him
against the blue jays
zero base on balls to nine k's that was
great for him work both sides of the
plate and he's gonna have to do that
tonight the yankees have first and third
one out here is luke voight
high drive left field going back duval
track wall see ya a long home run for
voight a three-run blast
and the yankees lead three-nothing
well it's like night and day you get the
bombers home at home and all of a sudden
they start hitting bombs again a
three-run homer right off the bat here
in the first inning luke voigt
fifth home run of the year now has 11
runs batted in
as ozuna is 90 feet away with one out
and johan camargo coming up
line to right field judge right there
and ozuna doesn't even think about it as
the throw comes all the way home
the 1-0
to austin riley is popped up and gonna
get out of the inning without a run
lemay you in back of second to make the
catch
double pump and slow it down
that off tooky's foot riley with a bare
hand throws to first and got sanchez by
a step
that was a missile let's see if tuki's
all right let's see where it got him
tooky with a kick save and a beauty it's
hockey season two good play by reilly
not to quit on it
and that took care of sanchez after a
long season
braves have a great threat two on nobody
out swanson darneau and freeman coming
up
popped up
lemay who makes the catch as flower
stays put at third
ground ball a second lemayo
and that'll do it here is aaron with two
on
man no one out two two
squib third base side charging is riley
throws the first not in time bases
loaded
hits sharply and they get the out they
fire the first and the ball gets away
charging home is lemayou and he will
score heads up base running by lemay
when they don't get the double play it's
four-nothing yankees so two-way forward
the lefty-hitting first baseman d.h for
the yankees tonight
the payoff swung on and line to right
field and that ball is over the head of
ozuna to the right center field wall
judge scores hicks scores it's a two-run
double from mike ford
and by the way it's a little bit of a
statement for mike getting a big hit
with two outs a line drive that soared
over the head of ozuna and one hop the
the little scoreboard right center and
the yankees now take a six nothing lead
oh here's judge
that one is drilled drilled to right
center no chance see ya up against a
toyota sign a bullet home run the other
way judge his ninth of the year a solo
shot and the yankees lead seven nothing
like i said earlier in this game when
the bombers come home they bomb and
aaron judge to me is a different hitter
in yankee stadium because he knows how
good right right center field players
cool off but that is the pace right now
let's see if they can turn two here
there's one
and there's two as hicks scores and it's
eight nothing yankees no rbi of course
frames have runners at first and second
for ozuna
all zuna drives this one deep left the
braves are going to be down five runs
that's how you get back in the game in
new york a three-run homer for ozuna
they're winning this inning it appears
marcel has his fourth 11 rbis
they have two on and
and they get a strikeout
for the first out of the inning
so anavino they'll face dansby swanson
with two on and one out
up the middle and
lemay hue and torres almost collide
everybody's safe that's twice they've
messed up in the middle infield and
atlanta gets a gift run it's eight to
four
put it in play and see what happens the
bases are loaded and marcel ozuna who
homered his last time up is back at the
plate
ground ball a third or shella goes the
short way and that will do it
here in the seventh
one on one out for ford
there's the three two runner goes pitch
line hard base hit over first down the
right field on rolling to the right
field corner extra base hit taurus
rounds third he will score easily
four to second with a double
so ford making a claim
for a d8 spot
has two doubles and three rbis that was
really tagged and the yankees take a 9-4
lead is that a tough night you might
have the chance there
there's a well-struck ball that's deep
right center field that's out toward the
bullpen that's going to ricochet off the
wall
and the braves have that runner coming
around third throw to the plate it's
gonna be late adam duvall never stopped
running he scores from first on a double
it's now a
nine two five game they can get a run if
he can put it in play in the outfield
but outs are dwindling to a precious few
the braves have five left
hot shot and a base hit that's down the
line that's going to make it 9-6
two hits in an error in the inning two
runs have scored for atlanta and they
bring in zach britton to try to get the
final three outs
fly ball right field talkman is there
and the yankees win this one 9-6 and
they just set a new yankee record
they've gone
26 straight series at home without a
loss